what could be more appropriate than for
us to gather today and encourage
all people especially people faith to
make sure that they get vaccinated
not only to protect themselves from
covid19
but more importantly to help protect
others from this terrible disease
by increasing the levels of immunity
within the population and by helping to
slow
the mutations of this virus that have
caused so many
even more infectious variants
as people of faith who are called to
love and care for our neighbors we
should be leading the way in this effort
and so we stand together or sit together
as the point may be
to send a clear message these vaccines
are a
great blessing they are a great
blessed advantage of that blessing
and we need to encourage others to do
the same
so thank you with us and in a few
minutes we'll have
some brief remarks from some special
guests that i would like to thank for
being here and
introduced to you the first is melissa
rogers who is the executive director of
the white house office
of faith-based and neighborhood
partnerships
so glad she's with us dr
perez estable who is director of nih's
national institutes on minority health
and health
disparities dr francis collins the
director of nih
and the man who needs no introduction dr
anthony fauci the director of the
national institute
of allergy and infectious disease i want
to thank those who are special guests
for being with us thank you so much
again we're so thrilled that you're here
with us and thanks to
all the jurisdictions who have come and
to support this event and to give
vaccines it's uh seems to me to be an
incredible blessing from god that we
were able to get all of this together
so thank you now i'll turn this over to
the man who not only thought of today's
event
but whose very hard work made it
possible the reverend dr
leonard hamlin who is our cathedral's
canon missioner
leonard
[Music]
thank you over the past
year words such as community spirit
compassion justice
and a host of other works have been
elevated in our vocabularies
the words are significant but they have
power only when they're connected
to our actions this evening
we have gathered in this space
recognizing the challenge
of this moment but we've come together
embracing the
opportunities that are in front of us
it is important that we encourage
everyone who is able to get vaccinated
faith leaders medical chiefs
managers regional officials
are all here to be defined by the
demographics
that often divide us but we are here
embracing
the truth that unites us a truth
that is probably characterized best in
words that i've always
heard growing up that because of our
the task ahead of us is not as great
as the power that is behind us
and so i remind us on today of the words
of robert frost that said two roads
diverged in a wood
and i took the one less traveled by
and that has made the difference
today we have come together that we
might make a difference
in the moment in which lives
are at stake and we recognize today
that everyone needs to be counted
and so words of one who has
was lifted here years ago that we all
know well
it is true as martin luther king jr said
in a real sense
all life is interrelated all men
are caught in an inescapable network of
mutuality
tied in a single garment of destiny what
affects
one directly affects all
indirectly we are all in this together
and so i'm thankful today to recognize
the faces that are on the platform
that are representing the medical
community
faith community as well as even the
educational community
and on this day i'd like to recognize
and say thank you
to county executive mark elrich
the county executive of montgomery
county maryland
i'd like to say thank you to george dr
george askew
deputy chief administration officer for
health and human
services education prince george's
county maryland
dr joseph wright who is vice president
and chief medical officer
of the university of maryland capital
health region
dr anker shah principal
senior deputy director district of
columbia
department of health i'd like to give a
special thanks to the reverend thomas
bowen
the mayor's office of religious affairs
of the district of columbia
who did a lot of heavy lifting with me
in this moment
and reaching around to help the
cathedral to live its mission
the washington national cathedral
i'd like to say thank you to dr rubin
varkeys public health director of
arlington county virginia
councilman john taylor chapman of
alexandria city council
dr hugh mighty dean of howard university
college of medicine
and vice president of clinical affairs
dr shelly mcdonald pickett pinkett
who is the interim chair of internal
medicine and chief medical officer
of howard university hospital dr
michael crawford associate dean of
strategy
outreach and innovation of howard
university
you've heard many names as well as
different communities represented but
today we come as one
because the only way to achieve success
in this moment
is by our reaching across and working
together
there is an old african proverb that
says if you want to go fast
go alone but if you want to go far
go together today we go together
good evening everyone i'd like to thank
national cathedral for organizing this
terrific event tonight and for inviting
us to participate
this is one great example of a
partnership
between government and faith-based
organizations
and as president biden has recognized
faith-based organizations can play
key roles in helping americans get
vaccinated
let me mention just a few reasons
government should work with
interested religious leaders and
faith-based organizations
on vaccination efforts first
houses of worship are pervasive and
familiar to many americans
countless americans are far more
comfortable
getting their shot in a house of worship
than in a pharmacy or a doctor's office
second religious figures are among the
most trusted community leaders
so seeing congregational leaders get
vaccinated first
can relieve anxieties and fears
the third reason why government and
faith-based organizations should work
together
in this task is that faith-based
organizations are often
highly skilled at reaching under-served
people
indeed congregational leaders haven't
simply turned over their
buildings for use as vaccination sites
they're also
manning the phones to get people
vaccinated
they're providing transportation to
vaccination sites and doing so many
other things to
make this task one that is doable for
everyone
fourth the vast majority of religious
leaders
are enthusiastic about helping the
country get vaccinated
many clergy have emphasized for example
that getting the vaccine is a way of
loving our neighbors
fifth governmental partnerships with
faith leaders to promote public health
are permitted
not prohibited by our constitution
indeed partnerships with diverse faith
communities can be a
powerful affirmation of our pluralism
and our unity across our differences in
background and belief
so in some governmental partnerships
with faith-based organizations
can and should be part of the solution
to the coven 19 challenge
as president biden has often said
there's nothing that americans can't do
when we do it together thank you
good afternoon i'm francis collins the
director of the national
institutes of health which we sometimes
like to call the national institutes of
hope
and i'm certainly here in a hopeful way
today
looking up at that stained glass window
in the twilight
reminded that i have a copy of that
hanging in my window in my home office
where i've essentially been a hermit for
the last 12 months
trying to manage the largest supporter
of biomedical research in the world
and i'm honored to be in this sacred
space again with these
leaders of multiple faiths
let us all recognize that the last year
has been one of struggle
and of lament for all of us
and yet we now have reasons for hope
as a believer and a scientist
i can see the opportunity to use the
tools of science
as a chance to be part of god's plan for
healing
the vaccines have in many ways from many
people been an
answer to prayer they are safe and
effective beyond
what we had a right to expect
and yet they will not help people by
sitting on the shelf
they need to be injected into the arms
of those who need them
unfortunately many who could most
benefit
because they are at highest risk of
serious and even
life-threatening infections are still
holding back
worried about stories they hear
skeptical unimpressed
by how government has previously shown
interest in their medical care
skeptical the church can play a
leading role by educating modeling
and encouraging that there is nothing to
fear here and there's much to be gained
that's what we are here to do today
houses of worship are houses of hope
here on this hill the national cathedral
represents that
and yes we all need hope at this time
but hope alone is not a strategy
today all of you are putting hope into
action
hope for an end to the terrible
suffering and loss of life
from covert 19. hope for an end to the
economic devastation it has caused
hope that the vaccine can not only
protect you
but also if we do this together your
family
your friends your community your nation
your whole world this is a love your
neighbor opportunity
to spread that hope far and wide
the jewish tradition has a metaphor
about community
the community is like a ship
but if there's a hole in the lower hold
of the ship
one does not say only the lower hold has
a hole in it
rather all must recognize the risk of
sinking
so everyone works to repair that breach
in order for us to get through this
challenge
of cobat 19 we must work together
to repair any breaches that might allow
that virus to continue
its terrible tragedy around us
all of us working together so my deepest
thanks to all who've gathered here all
who are listening
the other remarkable people on the
platform for joining in this plan
to repair any breaches in our ship of
vaccine
healing thank you very much
good evening my name is tony fauci and
i'm the director of the national
institutes of allergy and infectious
diseases
at the national institutes of health
i first wanted to underscore all the
important points
that were made by my colleague and
friend dr francis collins
but i also like to spend my couple of
minutes
talking to you a little bit about the
facts
and some of the fiction associated with
vaccines
how do these vaccines work i often get
asked that question by people
who understandably want to learn more
about what it is that's being injected
into their arm
vaccines that we have for covert 19
all have one thing in common it takes
a single protein of the virus
not the whole virus and that protein
gets expressed in different ways
depending upon what particular vaccine
platform that is being used in the
vaccine
that you will have some have a little
snippet of
messenger rna that codes for the protein
the spike protein on the virus others
are little harmless viruses that have
the dna for that spike protein
that when you inject it in it makes the
protein
the body thinks that it's the virus
but it's not the virus it's a harmless
protein component of the virus
so that when the body sees that it
thinks it's the virus
and it makes a very powerful immune
response
to protect you for when you do get
exposed
to the virus so how do we know these
vaccines
work we know they work
because they've been tested in tens of
thousands of individuals 30 000 people
in the modernity trial 44 000 people
in the fisa trial and forty thousand
people in the johnson and johnson or j
j trial and there's more to come
because there are also more vaccine
candidates that we're evaluating
a common question that we get asked
is how can you be sure that it's
actually safe and effective and the
answer is
because they've been tested in tens of
thousands of people and the decision
about whether it works namely is safe
and effective
is not made by the administration
not made by the congress not made by the
pharmaceutical company
it's made by an independent group
of scientists ethicists
statisticians who look at the data
and in an independent manner decide
whether it is safe and effective
then that data goes to the fda
whose career scientists look at it
and in association with their own
advisory committee
make a decision whether or not it should
be administered
to all of us myself included
so the answer is that the process
is both independent and transparent
another important question is but
telling us that it takes years to make a
vaccine
how could you possibly have a vaccine
when you just
knew the virus was a new virus in
january of 2020
and 11 months later you're injecting a
vaccine
into our arms and the reason is
the extraordinary scientific advances
that have taken place decades before
january twenty twenty
in other words things didn't start on
january tenth
twenty 2020 they started decades before
by large numbers of scientists who were
working their way
to the point where we could actually
have this vaccine
let me close by making a couple of
comments about
some of the myths about this particular
vaccine that we can understand how
people
can have these kinds of false rumors but
let's address them
we often get asked can you get covert 19
from the vaccine as i just told you
the vaccine is a small component
of the virus it's not the virus itself
so it is impossible to get covert 19
from the vaccine secondly
does it get into my dna it is
biologically impossible
for that to happen can it make me
sterile
there is no biological reason at all to
think
that that would happen and already tens
of thousands of people
have received the vaccine with no
significant adverse events
and then the one that's particularly
interesting to me
is that no neither are i and i believe i
can speak for bill gates
have put a chip into the virus when it
gets injected in you that might seem
ludicrous
but there really are things as
ridiculous as that
that are being circulated so
i want you all to realize that this
particular process
is very well controlled with the highest
standard
of ethics so i want to close by thanking
all of the people who've been vaccinated
as well as those who plan to get
vaccinated because what you're doing
is not only protecting yourselves
your families and your communities but
you're being part of the important
process
of ending this terrible pandemic that
has
essentially immobilized our country
and the world for the last year we will
get through this
and we will get through it by
vaccination
thank you
good afternoon my name is
i'm the director of the national
institute on minority health and health
disparities
and it is a real honor to be here to
talk to you today
for a few couple of minutes i recently
read that the washington cathedral
was the place where dr martin luther
king jr
gave his last sunday sermon just a few
days
before he was assassinated in memphis so
i thought that was fitting for us to be
here today
working to support and encourage all of
our communities
all of our communities of color to do
what we can do
to be safe and help end this pandemic
that has devastated so many so many
families
in this country and in the globe
today disparities have been shown by
covert 19.
this pandemic has illustrated inequities
in our society
that we knew about for decades but
really have
been been really put in contrast uh
in a rapid way in just a year
over 500 000 americans have died
over 50 of all cases and almost half of
all deaths
are in persons of african-american
latino or hispanic background
american indian and pacific islanders
now much has been said about well the
risk is greater because there's more
disease more diabetes more more obesity
more heart disease but the reality is
that the infections are more likely
because people live in more crowded
conditions
they work in jobs that do not do not
allow the privilege
of teleworking they cannot self-isolate
at home
because the two families three
generations
one bathroom these are just structural
realities
of this of the population in addition
many do not have computers depend on
their cell phone
for access to information and therefore
reaching this population
has become more of a challenge so this
risk
of economic inequality
educational inequality and occupational
differences
is what leads to these disparities
now at nih nimhd and
other institutes at nih our response has
been that we need to address this by
connecting with our communities
we have established a program called
community engaged
against covet 19 alliance or seal
for short with my colleague dr gary
gibbons who could not be here today
from the national national heart and
lung and blood institute
now dr fauci laid out all this
misinformation that's circulating out
there and there
is not uh it is everywhere all
communities are exposed to this
um our response is we need to address
this
misinformation directly with facts with
simple
facts not jargon based on data based on
science
and to promote trust in science
we have lost this we have not been ahead
of
this misinformation and it's time that
we started to do more of that
both in terms of the infection of how
it's transmitted
but also on the vaccine issue once it is
out and we have certainly focused on
that
this trust needs to be delivered by
trusted messengers
and you as faith-based leaders of all
denominations
are really critical in this effort much
like
local physicians nurses other healthcare
workers
and other trusted leaders in our
communities
we have a lot of uh faith that our seal
initiative
will make a difference in the states
that we have launched it
and we continue to work on expanding it
um
and turn towards vaccine uptake
so really creating the structures to
promote
make it easy for people to get
vaccinated such as
an event like this and other houses of
worship opening up
to um to being vaccinated
now i want to just close by saying that
i'm confident that this effort is going
to make a difference
i think all of us are eager uh to be
able to again see our loved ones
and share with people in person not zoom
i was vaccinated myself a little over
two weeks ago got my second shot
i went through the dc vaccine website it
wasn't easy but i got it done
and i think the easier we can make it as
we get more and more
people vaccinated the better we'll be
thanks everyone for um being here
for organizing this uh it really is
important
for all of us to be together to work
towards a better future
thank you
[Music]
i'm marianne buddy bishop of the
episcopal diocese of washington
after hearing such important remarks
from
our scientific and medical and
governmental communities
and in the presence of such esteemed
colleagues
in faith i'm honored to close this
portion
of our gathering in prayer may we begin
by simply calling to mind all those
we've lost
and those who suffer
and we thank you gracious god for all
who have worked so tirelessly
to bring the scourge of covet 19 in this
land and around the world
to an end we lament
the inequities and the injustices that
have caused so many to suffer needlessly
and we pray that this effort along with
others will help
overcome some of the disparities that
have divided us
let this vaccination effort be our
our marking event to create justice in
our society and our health care system
and to restore the trust that is so
needed for us to move forward
most of our gracious juan may those who
have dared to go
first be followed by those who go second
and followed by those who go third
fourth and fifth
so that we might by our
our example of following courage might
encourage others to be brave
and do the thing that scares us but also
allows us to be part
of this great journey toward restored
life
all this we ask in the gracious name of
god
amen
[Applause]
hmm
road
and then give the camera some time to
adjust and then we'll walk through the
table
you